bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du mardi 23 septembre du 7-8 journal le
journal de la rédaction de tv fil 26
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'information locale invité jean-luc
investir le président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
après avoir frôlé la cessation de
paiement l'an dernier la rentrée semble
se dérouler sans heurt quelles sont les
économies réalisées pour y arriver
plus de subventions et pas d'accès au
courant la ville de maurepas a repris en
main le tennis-club la conséquence de
graves dysfonctionnements selon le maire
ump grégory gare et astier et puis en
culture une exposition à bois d'arcy
l'association graphie de sartre présente
le travail de trois artistes des
portraits réalisés avec différentes
techniques
cette information tout d'abord qui
concerne la verrière comme nous l'avions
annoncé un conseil municipal
extraordinaire s'est bien déroulée
vendredi dernier avec pour ordre du jour
la sortie d'une partie de la ville de la
zone géographique prioritaire cette zone
qui permet de recevoir des dotations
supplémentaires de la part de l'état une
motion a été votée à l'unanimité pour y
maintenir les quartiers d'orly parc
encore le foyer adoma la nouvelle
secrétaire d'état chargée de la
politique de la ville sera prochainement
interpellé à ce sujet invité du journal
donc jean luc vaissière bonsoir monsieur
résidents de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines forcément la
première question portera sur l'état de
santé de l'établissement au risque de
cessation de paiement l'an dernier vous
aviez même annoncé une possibilité une
éventualité de fermeture
c'est en tout cas quelque chose qui
avait été évoqué aujourd'hui vous pouvez
nous dire que tout va mieux tout va
mieux alors tout va me sens vraiment
bien je dirais pas mais j'ai tout va
mieux puisque nous faisons la rentrée
les données dont je dispose aujourd'hui
sont plutôt encourageantes en termes d
étudiants malgré comme vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure si dans ce sens les
inscriptions par la voix la norme
allemande en affaires la fac de droit
jean cordier j'avais trois étudiants
étaient assis sur les marches en début
de semaine dernière donc c'est pas très
bien j'ai déjà vu des inscriptions juste
à côté dans le bâtiment d'alembert et
vauban en effet relations sociales donc
globalement c'est plutôt positif et
voire même plus d'étudiants ce qui est
pas forcément bien par rapport à nos
problématiques mais bon en termes
d'attractivité c'est important aux
rapports comme vous le souhaitiez de
faire
l'inquiétude qu'ils pouvaient s'être
développée chez ses parents dans les
partenaires pour dire voilà heurter à
des difficultés ce qu'il faut envoyer
des étudiants commencent l'année vous
avez vous allez dans ce jeu on a des
ambitions on est sûr au moins autant du
sud l'année dernière c'est à dire
sachant qu'on a terminé l'année à 20,20
1458 voilà donc ces voilà donc j'espère
qu'on va voir au moins atteindre ce
chiffre
ou à peu près même si on a fait quelques
modifications de l'offre de formation
l'on a pu faire l'objet un petit peu de
communication sur les tessinois on va
parler un petit peu des changements qui
sont annoncés les changements qu'il
commence à se mettre en place parce
qu'il va falloir faire des économies
mais on revient sur cette chronologie
peut-être des événements de la crise
novembre 2013 vous évoquez le risque de
cessation de paiement l'université ne
pourra pas payer le personnel si l'état
ne vient pas en aide à hauteur de 4
millions d'euros l'état et par
l'intermédiaire de la ministre geneviève
fioraso qui pointe des erreurs de
gestion de votre part de votre
prédécesseur également sylvie faucheux
d'ailleurs par la suite sera remercié de
son nouveau poste de recteur de dijon
l'état n'accorde que huit cent mille
euros pour finir l'année le bras de fer
se poursuit vous voter un budget en
déséquilibre ce qui n'est pas possible
ce qui n'est pas toléré c'est donc le
rectorat qui récupère la tutelle de
l'établissement qui doit proposer un
budget après le rapport de la cour des
comptes finalement qu'a dit ce rapport
et combien avez-vous réussi à obtenir de
la part de l'état voilà donc vous ça a
résumé très bien donc je veux pas
rentrer en détail cette escale
finalement depuis la mort ce qui
m'intéresse là c'est donc finalement la
cour des comptes le rapport il y avait
un rapport provisoire confidentiel qui a
dû diffuser allègrement je ne sais pas
par qui je le sais mais c'est pas
intéressant de le dire finalement le
rapport définitif est beaucoup plus
comment dire favorables mur citer qu'eux
au dessus on était alors que
généralement c'est la verse donc le
directeur de cabinet de la ministre
enfin madame cheveux rasés au musée
c'est surprenant mais voilà donc bon au
côté cour des comptes
effectivement ils ont pointé un certain
nombre de difficultés problèmes qu'on
s'attache à résoudre les difficultés sur
quoi qu'elle va le suivre la gestion sur
une université qui se développe qui n'a
pas forcément tous les outils toutes les
compétences ben c'est pas
effectivement ça a posé un problème
quand vous y est enfin sur en 2013
en mars 2013 je m'aperçois qu'on est
vraiment en difficulté sur le sur le
budget alors et demi après les choses
sont bien différentes
donc il ya eu des efforts très
importants qui ont été ont été réalisés
par la communauté je tiens vraiment à
associer toute la communauté
l'université qui s'est mobilisé au delà
des agacements des petits coups de
gueule comme on dit si mobilisés pour
pour rétablir la santé a obligé de faire
une cité puisque si je vous rappelle
résultats 2010 2012 c'était un déficit
de fonctionnement de 5 millions 2
aujourd'hui on est vers un résultat
positif de 2 millions 2 finalement
l'état a mis la main à la poche à la
main sur un portable cour des comptes
qui a pointé les dysfonctionnements qui
va falloir tarder correction en tout cas
des ajustements sur la façon de
fonctionner de l'université l'état à
verser combien donc pour le vol à voile
c'est comment vous avez bien signalé que
pour 2013 c'était 800 quelques 800 mille
euros pour le budget 2014 pour nous
permettre d'être à l'équilibré c'est
deux millions six cent trente mille
euros qu'il faudra rembourser
qui fera rembourser j'espère bien y
arriver je vous rappelle que la par
rapport à cela aujourd'hui on est sur un
résultat positif prévue au troisième set
de deux millions 2 donc on est presque
ali alors comment vous êtes arrivé à ce
résultat qu'elle fait voilà il ya eu des
efforts très importants qui ont été
faits par la communauté un jour jusqu'à
exploser par ailleurs pour dire voilà on
est vers un rétablissement la situation
financière qui est indispensable pour
rétablir notre crédibilité notre
viabilité mais cela s'accompagne de
l'a22 de mesures importantes en termes
de gel d'emploi de des emplois vacants
qui n'ont pas été republié savoir quelle
part est ce sont des enseignants
passionnés ils en sont chercheurs des
professeurs comme hooded des personnes
en australie finalement également donc
des réductions dans les dépenses de
fonctionnement du au quotidien pour
acheter du papier ou acheter des
produits chimiques
en chimie par exemple ça nous pénalise
pas les études ça ne pénalise pas aussi
les chercheurs on va dire que c'est pour
l'année 2014 donc une année assez dur en
termes d'addiction
ça passe à peu près donc en puisant dans
des réserves sur l'économie mais il est
clair que ce n'est pas tenable à moyen
terme donc là je pense qu'on a tous
consentis pour 2014 est fort important
il ya nécessaire pour 2015 de desserrer
un petit peu je parlais tous les courts
dont vous allez réussir pasqua la région
parce que argent qu'il faut rembourser
les universités sont autonomes et
maintenant donc il faut faire rentrer de
l'argent le contexte est compliqué
quelles sont vos pistes
donc voilà entrer de l'argent dans
l'univers soit là et serrer l'étau voilà
donc là aujourd'hui
étant plutôt pragmatique je lis plutôt
sur la réduction des dépenses que sur
les rentrées d'argent qu'on voulait y
aller le contexte est pas forcément un
travail sans rentrer sur la
problématique de la réforme la taxe
d'apprentissage mais donc voilà on est
plutôt aujourd'hui sur une logique donc
on était sur une logique d'évolution des
dépenses que j'ai évoquées personnel
fonctionnement voire investissement donc
on va essayer de maintenir sur 2015 on
espère toujours un soutien moindre mais
quand même un soutien de l'état
remboursables bien sûr pour rétablir la
santé et j'engage maintenant dès cet
automne une grande réflexion prospective
au sein d'universités pour voilà pour
voilà comment on voit l'union 6 vers
saint sacrement eglin à l'horizon 2020
cette tendance à la java ça mais c'est
pas forcément seulement entre par
exemple deux tendances et dire voilà on
a un contrat quinquennal qui commence en
2004 à 2009
on a quatre cinq ans pour réfléchir à
l'évolution diversité pour un petit peu
concentré notre ces régions des gardiens
dans les activités on a par exemple vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure ça ne fait
pas partie
voilà la réalité pour l'université c'est
la filière d'éducation qui revient après
si vous vouliez plus en détails parce
que ça peut créer quelques mois mais
l'objectif c'est dire la lune c'est un
projet stratégique de contribuer à la
construction d'universités paris saclay
avec des grandes écoles n'ont pas eu
grand organisme merci telle versailles
saint quentin en yvelines a des qualités
indéniables en termes de formation de
recherche
on a besoin c'est différent c'est dans
cet environnement un petit peu complexe
et on a besoin de cultiver notre qualité
parce qu'on se doit
on se doit de former nos étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent s'insérer correctement
on a un devoir de qualité en termes de
formation de nos étudiants en termes de
production de connaissances en termes
d'innovation au trilogie voilà il faut
qu'on concentre nos moyens sur nos
qualités et donc sur quelles filières
spécifiquement jeu ils sont les filières
qui vous semblent prioritaires les les
qualités le plus la plus value de
l'université il ya des choses qui sont
assez évidentes redon vous avions déjà
parlé sur sur les sciences de
l'environnement je ne voudrais pas qu'on
a appliqué dans les programmes curiosity
sur mars
rosetta sur la comète bientôt peut-être
un événement sur sur 50 à guyancourt
bientôt sur le sujet également en chimie
sur le matériau sur le patrimoine en
informative sur la cryptologie au hasard
je veux pas amérique c est en tout cas
la loi sur le sport l'éducation physique
donc la fonde sur cette question c'est
la première année staps donc éducation
physique sportive qui a été fermée cette
année et après ça sera 2e et 3e voilà
exactement douglas est un choix george
est pas à rougir je pense que c'est un
choix qui m'honore c'est peut-être un
peu fort mais jeudi alger les
responsabilités en tant que trait
intercités un déclic je dire je ne peux
pas accepter à mercier des étudiants qui
auront pas une formation pédagogique
convenable pour leur insertion
professionnelle
ils ne font une filière où il n'ya pas
les enseignants et c'est le constat que
j'ai fait j'ai essayé toutes les
manières à l'enseignant aujourd'hui pour
assurer là quand je dis je caricature
c'est à dire que j'ai deux enseignants
chercheurs titulaires pour encadrer 200
étudiants non c'est pas possible
sans parler comme j'ai évoqué de la
problématique de l'accès aux
infrastructures sportives
je tiens à remercier monsieur le maire
de guyancourt pour nous aider dans ce
titre bénévole fin on paye pas mais il
s'est forcément en dehors des créneaux
scolaires
on passe après donc c'est vraiment trop
compliqué moi je ne peux pas accepter de
voir le suivant je suis pas capable de
former que j'ai pas l'encadrement
nécessaire d'autant qu' il ya des staps
à or c'est donc pas très loin un autre
côté du plateau de saclay où il ya un
encadrement bien pu satisfaire
vous avez donc redéfini des choix des
priorités on va poursuivre l'échangé
avec vous on va juste faire une pause
nous sommes allés rencontrer quelques
étudiants pour leur demander on fait
rentrer ce qu'ils pensaient de leur
université université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
elle est agréable le cadrer
et sympathie qu'on a
un grand parc c'est un bon milieu pour
être ici je pense le meilleur taux de
réussite c'était chez nous et
apparemment on est passés 36e maintenant
donc ça ça m'étonne pas forcément sûr
mais moins de moyens dans nos cours
après il n'est pas étonnant qu'elle ait
lyon qui réussissent moins derrière à
fut très content on étudie bien ici on
réussit ici et ça c'est pas donné à tous
franchement la crise budgétaire
globalement été bien gérée parce que
nous en tant qu'étudiant on n'a pas
ressenti tant que ça voilà donc c'est
vrai que l'année dernière en fin d'année
ça a été un peu dure pas
l'année dernière déjà il y avait manqué
des feuilles pour les imprimantes
après ce que j'ai su et des profs qui
était à moitié pas payé et le sujet des
manques de chauffage n'ont pas de
chauffage pas de feuille on ça peut
paraître des détails quand on est à deux
doigts de la cessation de paiement et
qu'on pense à fermer l'université mais
ça reste à des difficultés pour pour les
enseignants pour les étudiants et
d'ailleurs pour ces étudiants pour
rebondir il y avait une contestation
autour des économies réalisées sur les
horaires de la bibliothèque
universitaire lui avec universitaire
vous avez dû resserrer les horaires il
ya des changements à venir
dois je crois encore que côtoyons tous
les deux ou twitter j'ai vu formation
d'étudiants qui étaient contents de
leurs actions qui permettait d'ouvrir
d'élargir les horaires rigueur qui fait
à cet après midi lorsqu'ils ont vu que
vous veniez en plateau ouais c'est ça
pour le moment d'avoir fait pression sur
l'université voilà obtenir lula pourrait
donner à remercier je pense que je j'ai
eu à
anticiper leur demande donc notamment
sur l'hypothèque qui est juste à côté de
dissidents simple pour le samedi 9 ans a
fait les efforts ensuite on a un souci
également vous en parlait peut-être
moins à ce que c'est parce que saint
quentin la biotech pour les étudiants en
médecine
ambroise paré à boulogne si cassy ja
plus compliqué qu'on a résolues donc ça
veut dire que la fallu faire des efforts
financiers on y revient vous avez
commencé à desserrer cet étau ça des
conséquences budgétaires
les rentrées d'argent les économies
c'est pour maintenant swiss a donc
apprécié là on gère la séquence ouvrira
samedi ces quelques centaines d'euros
voilà donc ce n'est pas monstrueux non
plus à gérer mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut donc je pense qu'on sait je sais
définir des priorités
on peut pas dire que je n'ai pas la
problématique de la réussite des
étudiants même si effectivement on
pourrait faire mieux dans un contexte un
peu compliqué mais bon j'ai entendu les
étudiants interviewé dans cette séquence
qui ne sont pas forcément en forçant ils
seront 25 et on est certain de
rencontrer non plus voilà mais le rendre
à l'état surveille actuellement le
budget à oui biensur et donc je diverses
étaient toujours sous tutelle ouais si
ça vous plaît comme tu en voilà assez ce
que c'est le terme consacré à ses sous
tutelle et je trouve ça c'est un peu
violent comme ça mais on accompagné par
l'état et par le recteur se faire
accompagner à sous tutelle mais il
n'empêche que c'est son succès le terme
vous êtes bien aujourd'hui observée est
scruté justifié c'est normal et pions
d'autant plus que l'état nous aide
donc je ne me paraît pas inconvenant que
l'état soit sur 6 e de l'utilisation de
cette dotation exceptionnelle et je
tiens d'ailleurs à allouer la relation
que je peux avoir aujourd'hui avec
madame se fait à l'état ou ministre
influent raso son cabinet et puis la
direction dans ses mots ce père donc on
a de très bonnes relations
et je considère que j'ai un soutien
significatif aujourd'hui vous nous
l'avez dit l'état surveille activement
le budget renoue flash vous soutiens
mais le surveille aussi les dépenses qui
sont engagés ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
plus de grands projets pour l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin aujourd'hui
là il faut de grands projets tous mis en
suspens je sais pas ce que vous appelez
un grand projet un grand projet en
termes de l'immobilier n'ont aujourd'hui
enfin il ya des projets d'aménagement de
concentration d'amélioration de la
gestion du patrimoine immobilier
mais là aujourd'hui il n'est pas
question de construire de nouveaux
bâtiments
aujourd'hui la perspective il ya des
gros projets et des grands projets de
développement qualitatif vous ai dit
tout à l'heure la fusion stratégie la
qualité ne sait comment se positionne de
saclay ça c'est un gros projet qu'on
adore le rapprochement avec un simple
sur saclay voilà ça c'est déjà un projet
scientifique politique stratégique qui
nous paraît important parce que moi pour
nous estime également le directoire
notamment directoire de 2,51 et bim
merci jean yves dusserre président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines universités
qui fait sa rentrée après une année
difficile et les choses sont bien
engagées en tout cas c'est ce que vous
nous dites ce soir jour merci à vous
sentez et l'association mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque qui se lance dans le
yoga de l'association qui permet à des
enfants souffrant de venir en france
pour être opéré vient de proposer une
opération baptisée les yogis du coeur
une séance collective 700 personnes
réunies dans un cadre impressionnant
l'orangerie du château de versailles
afin bien sûr de récolter des fonds
lionel torrès patrick jacques de dixmude
loin de l'agitation habituelle le calme
règne à l'orangerie du château de
versailles organisé par l'association
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque
cette première édition des yogis du
coeur a réuni 700 personnes pour une
séance un peu particulière
j'ai été très étonné de voir le
d'entendre le silence de 700 personnes
dans temps les vibrations des
respirations et je n'aurais jamais
imaginé qu'une séance de yoga avec 700
personnes puissent se réaliser du
meilleur possible
c'est vrai que côté des sons ou des
choses comme ça une espèce d'osmos qui
se crée entre entre tout le monde
ac c'est sympa ça fait un petit peu
vibrer quoi l'endroit est absolument
magnifique le cadre est magique
c'était parfait allez
ça a été très agréable parce que je
savais que des toutes sortes de
personnes allaient se retrouver ici et
j'ai trouvé une qualité d'attention très
intéressante
lors de cet événement l'objectif pour
l'association est de récolter un maximum
de fonds pour opérer deux enfants
malades du coeur la mission semble
accomplie c'est un bel événement j'en
suis très heureuse il va nous permettre
d'opérer deux enfants il va nous
permettre de faire mieux connaître
mécénat de fédérer encore de nouveaux
amis voyez c'est ça beaucoup comme on
dit un bon coup depuis ses débuts en
1996 l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque a permis à plus de 2000
enfants de se faire opérer du coeur en
france le tennis-club de maurepas sans
subvention sans terrain décision prise
par le conseil municipal qui reproche à
son président l'utilisation de faux
documents des manquements à plusieurs de
ses obligations la réélection a été
jugée disproportionnée par les adhérents
mais la situation a changé ces dernières
antonia les cours sont encore à la
reille mais ils sont désormais quinze
bénévoles a dirigé le tennis-club de
maurepas ce vendredi lors de l'assemblée
générale extraordinaire
un nouveau comité directeur a été élu
l'ancien trésorier franck godfrain
reprend en main le destin d'un club
meurtri et michel enault après huit
années de présidence ne quitte pas pour
autant le bateau moi je tenais à
continuer parce que je suis investi et
puis mon
je souhaite continuer avec dans ce
club-là même si d'autres clubs m'ont
sollicité pour venir les aider mais je
préfère continuer sur nos repas fin mai
la ville constate alors que le club et
son président de l'époque michel enault
n'a pas convoqué l'assemblée générale
l'an passé ni renouvelé son comité
directeur réduits de huit à trois
membres et lui reprochent l'utilisation
de faux documents pour obtenir une
subvention communale annuelle de 6600
euros
début septembre le maire convoque alors
un conseil municipal extraordinaire pour
suspendre la subvention l'association du
tennis
et puis pour également arrêter la mise à
disposition des locaux tout en sachant
que nous avons permis quand même aux
adhérents du club pour pas les pénaliser
parce que c'est surtout ça parce que
c'est une situation qui était comme
compliquée inédite de permettre aux
adhérents de s'inscrire au travers du
service des sports pour pouvoir faire
toujours du tennis au sein de des locaux
l'école de tennis devait reprendre ce
lundi et aura probablement une semaine
de retard par rapport à la date prévue
le club qui craint un exil d'une partie
de ses 420 licenciés devra rebondir dans
les semaines prochaines
suite à l'assemblée générale l'ensemble
des documents officiels ont été transmis
aux services municipaux
on laisse la polémique de côté pour
parler véritablement de sport et de
handball habitués de la nationale 2 chez
les féminines montigny entame un nouveau
cycle avec des jeunes joueuses et elle
vise aussi la montée en fin de saison
mais le club ni mon teint à d'ores et
déjà raté son départ face au havre
c'était lors de la première journée a
résumé anthony rech
lorsque l'on joue la montée en fin de
saison il faut pouvoir s'imposer face
aux gros du championnat la réception du
havre on ressemblait à s'y méprendre au
premier test pour montigny relégué de
national une la réserve havrais imposer
un défi physique d'entrée aux
coéquipières de gabriel par le r d in i
monteyne tiennent la cadence pendant
près de 20 minutes
mais l'écart au score se creuse
inexorablement à la pause montini accuse
un retard de cinq buts 14 9 en faveur du
havre ans partait avec envie de gagner
forcément plus quand je la monte sa part
sa part dès la première journée
après
ouais je pense qu'en première mi temps
on a réussi à
tenir en moins 20 minutes et puis après
et puis après l'impact physique et la
supériorité technique des havraises se
fait sentir
les joueuses de philippe l'étrange ne
parviennent pas à mettre leur jeu en
place et manque cruellement d'efficacité
au tir avec seulement 35 % de réussite
le havre s'impose finalement 35 20 les
cinq buts de hugh bénézis n'y feront
rien une première défaite face à un
candidat à la montée qui monte rosine et
monteyne le travail qu'il leur reste à
faire
environnement construire des bâtiments
en terre la technique traditionnelle a
encore de beaux jours devant elle la
bouche pour les initiés plus précisément
l'association saint quentin en
transition s'est lancé dans la
construction d'un cabanon en terre crue
découverte de cette méthode 100% naturel
avec ce reportage de claire cambier
voilà donc là le mur ici a pas encore eu
de
de lever donc on va ici mettre la terre
donc avant je me dis fille le mur pour
faire une belle touche beaucoup
j'accroche charles prépare la prochaine
levée de bojan entendez par là de terre
et de paille
avec ces techniques de construction
ancestrales l'association sky en
transition compte équiper le jardin
pédagogique de magny les hameaux d'une
cabane à outils un projet lancé il ya
maintenant un nom c'est une démarche en
fait oui on va dire écologique mais
aussi c'est aussi économique pour nous
pour l'association parce qu'en fait tous
les matériaux proviennent du site où
nous sommes nous avons pris la terre
pour construire justement le mur en
terre nous avons aussi fait un mélange
de foin qui viennent des environs on a
eu en fait à mettre gratuitement juste
en allant le chercher
et pareil le soubassement étant molière
donc la pierre locale qui se trouvait
vraiment dans les chants qu'on a enlevé
quand on a commencé à aménager le jardin
là bas pour éviter les infiltrations
d'eau les fondements sont en pierre et
le cabanon sera bientôt équipé d'un toit
assez large pour protéger les murs
quatre personnes de l'association suivi
une formation construction en terre une
dizaine de bénévoles vient les aider
régulièrement je me suis des chaussées
je suis rentré dans la boue a piétiné
après prendre les les notes de d'argile
kulesza sur la baraque c'est très
ludique pour le mélange terre fois on
n'hésite pas à mettre les pieds dans la
boue
donc maintenant là le mélange est
parfaitement
lisez donc on va le sortir de la fosse
on va le mettre donc dans les dents les
brouettes pour pouvoir la mener au
niveau du mur a monté le mur en bauges
vont peu à peu
aujourd'hui il va atteindre sa hauteur
finale dernière étape de la journée
battre le mur c'est vraiment ça qui fait
que le mur va bien se tenir
ça permet de bien relié toute la paille
et la terre dont quelques jours une fois
que le mur sera séchée on égalisera
l'ensemble avec cette pelle et pour
contrer les idées reçues ce type de
construction peut tenir jusqu'à 400 ans
on termine par de la culture avec ce
reportage d'aurélia de bissy et de
patrick jacques de dixmude consacré à
l'exposition de street art à découvrir
en ce moment à bois d'arcy des artistes
qui exposent des portraits réalisés avec
leur technique de prédilection le que
quelques tableaux accrochés et
l'exposition sera fin prête
fruit du travail de trois passionnés de
street art ce mouvement artistique né
dans les rues au début des années 80
exposition collective et la retrouver à
bois d'arcy
à l'heure où les tableaux de street art
sa rage dans les galeries et vente aux
enchères des grandes métropoles l'espace
barragué accueille les oeuvres de
l'association car 6 yens graphique par
jusqu'au 27 septembre
il met tous issus de la culture hip hop
du street art on a commencé par tout ce
qui est des graffitis donc lettrage sur
toile et on a ensuite modifié notre
style au fur et à mesure des années donc
enfin tout en gardant ce côté hip hop on
a un peu changé les styles en se basant
à ce conte sur des portraits donc ça
peut être tout ans a peut être des
images que l'on voit sur internet qui
nous plaisent des portraits engageant
des portraits engager des reproductions
de photos d'artistes ou de personnages
de films exposition présente ici une
vision sur toile de trois artistes
d'urbain cette toile donc c'est un
enfant prises par un photographe donc
lors du conflit israélo palestinien
je la décris de gaza j'ai utilisé
uniquement
de la crise j'ai tout fait on pense aux
oeufs
chose que je n'avais jamais fait
auparavant mais toujours utilisé donc
des fêtes propose cas où des pro
marqueur à noter enfin que l'association
propose également toute l'année des
cours de dessin merci de nous avoir
suivi le journal revient demain même
heure d'ici là nous replay a consulté
sur le site internet de téléphiles votre
soirée sur notre antenne c'est notamment
avec claire cambier pour un 7 8 société
consacrée aux personnes âgées au volant
est finalement un véritable risque débat
à suivre
à demain